Hi there, it's Marianne here. Before we dive into today's episode, I want to quickly let you know about something exciting that's happening right now. If you've ever wondered how to create income that works for you, rather than constantly trading your time for money, then you'll love the Race to Recurring Revenue Challenge with my business mentor, Lisa Johnson. This challenge is designed to help you build sustainable income streams. And whether you're an aspiring psychologist, a mental health professional, or in a completely different field,
大家好，我是Marianne。在进入今天的话题之前，我想快速告诉大家一件正在发生的令人兴奋的事情。如果你曾经想过如何创造为你工作的收入，而不是不断地用时间换金钱，那么你一定会喜欢我和我的商业导师Lisa Johnson共同发起的“经常性收入竞赛”（Race to Recurring Revenue Challenge）。这项挑战旨在帮助你建立可持续的收入来源。无论你是一位有抱负的心理学家、心理健康专业人士，还是来自完全不同的领域，
the principles can work for you. There are also wonderful prizes to be won directly by Lisa herself. And if you join the challenge by my link, you can be in with a chance of winning a one-to-one hours coaching with me, Dr. Marianne Trent. Do you want to know more? Of course you do. Head to my link tree, Dr. Marianne Trent, or check out my social media channels, or send me a quick DM and I'll get you all the details. Right, let's get on with today's episode. Coming up in today's episode, I am joined by Dr. Alistair Teager, who returns to the podcast this time to talk with us about his experiences of helping set up a new service in Ukraine. It
这些原则都同样适用。此外，还有由Lisa本人提供的丰厚奖品。如果你通过我的链接加入挑战，你还有机会赢得与我——Marianne Trent博士进行一对一辅导的机会。想了解更多吗？当然想。请前往我的Linktree页面（Dr. Marianne Trent），查看我的社交媒体频道，或者直接给我发私信，我会告诉你所有细节。好了，让我们开始今天的节目吧。在今天的节目中，我邀请到了Alistair Teager博士，他再次回到播客，与我们分享他在乌克兰协助建立新服务的经历。这
is a fascinating listen. We talk through all kinds of things, and I hope you'll find it so useful. Thank you. The Aspiring Psychologist Podcast with Dr. Marianne Trent. Hi, welcome along to the Aspiring Psychologist Podcast. I am Dr. Marianne Trent and I'm a qualified clinical psychologist. I've said it before, and I will likely say it again. I just love how varied our career in psychology and mental health can be. I love that the last time we met my guest for today, who is Dr. Alastair Teager, we were talking about how to get an assistant psychologist job. And in case you're wondering, that is episode 52. So you can watch that on YouTube or take a listen via Spotify or Apple podcasts. And you know, that was a really well received episode. And today we are talking about the fact that shortly after we recorded that episode, he went off to Ukraine and has been there a few different times to help us think about how we can use our skills to benefit others in perhaps very
是一次引人入胜的访谈。我们讨论了各种各样的话题，希望你会觉得非常有用。谢谢。这里是《有抱负的心理学家播客》，我是Marianne Trent博士。嗨，欢迎收听《有抱负的心理学家播客》。我是Marianne Trent博士，我是一名合格的临床心理学家。我以前说过，以后可能还会再说，我非常热爱心理学和心理健康领域的职业多样性。我很高兴上次见到今天的嘉宾Alistair Teager博士时，我们讨论的是如何获得助理心理学家的工作。如果你好奇的话，那是第52期节目。你可以在YouTube上观看，或者通过Spotify或Apple Podcasts收听。那期节目反响非常好。今天我们要谈论的是，在那期节目录制后不久，他去了乌克兰，并多次前往那里，帮助我们思考如何利用我们的技能去造福他人，在那些或许与我们所学或所熟悉的
different contexts than that which we learned them in or which we're familiar with ourselves honestly just a privilege to talk to him I hope that you all gain a lot from it we do mention a concept called moral injury and I thought it might just be useful for me to explain what that is in case you don't know already. So this was a term that I only really became aware of during the pandemic. And it was something that was cropping up for people, health staff, for example, who were having to make decisions over who to treat, who to give certain technology to if there's only certain amounts available. And then afterwards, having to then deal with the consequences of those decisions
完全不同的环境中。坦率地说，能与他交谈是一种荣幸，希望大家都能从中获益良多。我们提到了一个叫“道德伤害”（moral injury）的概念，我想如果我能解释一下它是什么，可能会对大家有帮助，以防你还不知道。这是我在疫情期间才真正了解到的一个术语。它在一些人群中出现，例如医护人员，他们不得不做出关于治疗谁、如果资源有限该把特定技术提供给谁的决定。事后，他们不得不面对这些决定的后果，
of that moral decision. And you kind of can have a trauma presentation. So that's what moral injury is. So yeah, just to save you a Google i i like this to be a one-stop shop for useful stuff for you um if you've got any ideas for future podcast episodes please do get in contact with me and let me know please also if you do value this content please do rate and review it both on spotify and or apple podcasts and if you're watching this on YouTube, please do like, subscribe, share the content to help us get this word of the podcast that is getting really lovely feedback to as many people as possible. Don't let me stop you. Let's dive in. Let's reconnect with Alistair and I will see you on the other side of this.
这种道德决策带来的后果。你可能会出现创伤表现，这就是道德伤害。所以，为了省去你们谷歌搜索的麻烦，我希望这里能成为你们获取有用信息的一站式平台。如果你对未来的播客节目有任何想法，请务必联系我并告诉我。另外，如果你觉得这些内容有价值，请务必在Spotify或Apple Podcasts上进行评分和评论。如果你是在YouTube上观看，请点赞、订阅并分享这些内容，帮助我们将这个获得极好反馈的播客传播给更多人。别让我停下来，让我们深入探讨吧。让我们与Alistair重新连线，我在节目的另一端等你。
Just want to welcome our guest back to the podcast today because we met Dr Alistair previously when we were talking about how to get assistant psychologist jobs but we were also discussing the very exciting and potentially a little bit worrying trip that you were about to make Alistair which was to go to Ukraine. Welcome back, thanks for being here. Thanks for having me, much appreciated. So can you tell us a little bit about what your experiences were like when you went to Ukraine? Yeah of course would help to I suppose give a bit of the background to how it came about you know. Sure that would be great. I don't think it's something I thought I was going to be doing as a an aspiring clinical psychologist so yeah coming out of training I worked in neuropsychology I also worked in major trauma center so with people with
今天想欢迎我们的嘉宾回到播客，因为我们之前见过Alistair Teager博士，当时我们讨论的是如何获得助理心理学家的工作，但我们也讨论了你即将进行的那个非常令人兴奋且可能有点令人担忧的旅行，那就是去乌克兰。欢迎回来，谢谢你能来。谢谢你的邀请，非常感激。那么，你能告诉我们一些你在乌克兰的经历吗？当然，我想先介绍一下这件事是如何发生的。好的，那太好了。我不认为这是我作为一名有抱负的临床心理学家会做的事情，所以，在完成培训后，我在神经心理学领域工作，也曾在重大创伤中心工作，接触过
brain injuries spinal injuries musculoskeletal injuries and I suppose as a part of that when I was working or overseeing the major trauma service, the Ariane de Grande concert bombing happened, so the Manchesterina attack. And we're based at Salford. So we had a number of people come to our hospital as part of the major incident. So we provide a lot of acute psychosocial care. And then more recently, we've sort of developed a bit of spinal cord injury service as well so i suppose thinking about ukraine and what's going on there in the war um and sort of some of my areas of expertise i think the the world health organization
脑损伤、脊髓损伤、肌肉骨骼损伤的患者。我想，作为其中的一部分，当我在工作或监督重大创伤服务时，发生了阿里安娜·格兰德演唱会爆炸案，也就是曼彻斯特爆炸案。我们当时在索尔福德。所以，作为重大事件的一部分，我们医院接收了许多人。我们提供了大量的急性心理社会护理。最近，我们还发展了一些脊髓损伤服务。所以，我想在考虑乌克兰以及那里正在发生的战争时，结合我的一些专业领域，我认为世界卫生组织
reached out to a number of services including um the stoke mandville, which is the National Spinal Cord Injury Centre. And I'm in a couple of networks with guys from there. And Dr. Jane Duff, who's the lead there, she kind of knew my background and thought, actually, this is probably up your street or within your wheelhouse. So, yeah, they were trying to set up a national rehabilitation center for um casualties of the war civilians and military um with an onus on spinal cord injury and traumatic brain injury so i suppose that's where i thought actually that's probably something i can offer um i wanted to be able to to do something, but wasn't sure that was. And then this landed in my email inbox and I thought, you know,
联系了包括斯托克曼德维尔（Stoke Mandeville）在内的多家服务机构，那是国家脊髓损伤中心。我和那里的人在几个网络中有联系。那里的负责人Jane Duff博士了解我的背景，认为这可能很适合我，或者在我的能力范围内。所以，他们当时正试图为战争中的伤员——平民和军人——建立一个国家康复中心，重点是脊髓损伤和创伤性脑损伤。所以我想，这可能是我能提供帮助的地方。我希望能做点什么，但不确定那是什么。然后这个机会出现在我的收件箱里，我想，
I'm going to follow that up really. So, yeah, I suppose that's a bit of the backdrop to it. Yeah. Yeah, like it's an incredible career that we're in, isn't it? That sometimes something will just drop into your emails that you weren't necessarily pursuing but once you you know once you know about it you're like oh that that is intriguing I think I would like that I think I would do that well and it's that flexibility of our skills but also
我真的要跟进这件事。所以，这就是背景。是的，我们从事的职业真是不可思议，不是吗？有时一些事情会直接掉进你的邮箱，你并没有刻意去追求，但一旦你知道了，你就会觉得，哦，这很有趣，我想我会喜欢，我想我会去做。而且，这体现了我们技能的灵活性，以及
our eagerness to learn and to support and you know help people as well I think yeah I mean I think I've never been particularly ambitious to want to do one thing or the other but I've been sometimes in the right place at the right time and perhaps a bit opportunistic um and obviously with it being that um the war in Ukraine people were incredibly supportive from from my hospital um Northernolines they were they wanted to be able to support the effort in some way so they were able to you know provide me with the the leave but also permission to to explore it really so yeah just went from there really great and how long were you there for so um i worked there off and on between start of December and end of March,
我们学习和支持他人的渴望。我想，是的，我从来没有特别雄心勃勃地想做某事，但我有时处于正确的时间和地点，也许有点机会主义。显然，因为那是乌克兰战争，我医院的同事们非常支持，他们希望以某种方式支持这项工作，所以他们能够为我提供假期，也允许我去探索它。所以，事情就是从那里开始的。太棒了，你在那里待了多久？所以，我在12月初到3月底之间断断续续地在那里工作，
but I was effectively doing about two weeks in Ukraine and then coming back, working in the NHS for two weeks, then going back to Ukraine for two weeks. But it's quite difficult because I suppose contextually, you know, it is a war zone, so it would take me two or three days to get to the hospital where we're working and that's because i have to fly into poland well for starters i'd have to get from chester to stansted which is where most of the flights go to a place called jejov in poland then i'd stay there overnight then i'd have to get a UN vehicle across the border to Lviv.
但我实际上是在乌克兰工作两周，然后回来在NHS工作两周，然后再去乌克兰两周。但这相当困难，因为从背景来看，那是一个战区，所以我需要两三天才能到达我们工作的医院，因为我必须先飞往波兰。首先，我得从切斯特到斯坦斯特德，那是大多数航班飞往波兰热舒夫（Jzeszow）的地方，然后我在那里住一晚，接着我必须乘坐联合国的车辆穿过边境到达利沃夫。
And then I'd stay over there overnight because you're not allowed to travel in UN vehicles during nighttime. And then you've got to line up with them when the transports happen. So then the next day I'd get a lift up to where we were based. So it's quite disjointed, but also understandably so. So if I was out there for 14 to 16 days, I might only be in the hospital for eight days because of the travel restrictions, really. And I think personally, I went out for a week in December to start just to get a feel for it, which was really useful because it's quite anxiety provoking to think about where I was going um possibly more for my mum less so my dad when they heard what I was going to be doing um so I think it provided them with a bit of a reassurance and also it's kind of a dry run for me you know sort of get to know the country a bit get to know what the needs were and then I went back in uh in first week of
然后我在那里住一晚，因为晚上不允许乘坐联合国的车辆。然后你必须在运输发生时与他们排队。第二天，我会被送到我们驻扎的地方。所以这相当脱节，但也可以理解。所以如果我在那里待14到16天，由于旅行限制，我可能只有8天在医院。我认为个人而言，我在12月去了一周，只是为了感受一下，这非常有帮助，因为想到我要去的地方确实让人焦虑，可能对我妈妈来说比对我爸爸更担心，当他们听到我要做什么时。所以我认为这给了他们一些安慰，对我来说也是一次预演，了解一下这个国家，了解需求是什么，然后我在1月的第一周又回去了，
January um to sort of, I suppose, start the work in earnest. So, yeah, that's that side of things. It was, it's a beautiful country. I've loved being out there, like, experiencing the culture and stuff, but it's also incredibly daunting and humbling to see what they're going through and what we can come back to. Yeah.
开始认真工作。所以，这就是那一方面的情况。那是一个美丽的国家。我喜欢在那里，体验文化等等，但看到他们正在经历的事情以及我们能回到什么样的地方，也感到非常令人畏惧和谦卑。是的。
Yeah, I feel like I've learned a tiny amount of culture from some Ukrainian refugees my mum had staying with her for a while and seeing their pictures of, you know, their homes and their areas where they'd lived before. It was beautiful. And then seeing, you know, what it had been raised to. It was, you know, just tragic. And it's real people, you know.
是的，我觉得我从我妈妈接待过一段时间的一些乌克兰难民那里学到了一点点文化，看到他们以前居住的家园和地区的照片。那很美。然后看到它们被夷为平地，真是太悲惨了。那是真实的人，你知道。
It's really, really emotive, isn't it? And we're recording this, Alistair, as you know, just tragic. And it was real people, you know, it's really, really emotive, isn't it? And we're recording this, Alistair, as you know, in the time when actually there's lots and lots in the media about the Israel attacks and the atrocities that have been happening there. And I was in a private practice discussion for someone who was a clinical psychologist that lives and works in Israel, but had trained in the UK and was really trying to help people, you know, in a crisis situation, but isn't necessarily a trauma therapist and was saying, how can I do this? How can I be help? How can I be help? And, you know, I also work in trauma. I was saying, well, it's very difficult to try and help people find safety when there's so many unanswered questions and when when we can't get that felt sense of safety. And of course, when we're doing trauma work, it's partly it's what we're having to say to people. It's over now. You know, how do you do that? How do you manage that when you're in an ongoing situation?
这真的很感人，不是吗？Alistair，我们录制这期节目时，正如你所知，那是真实的人，你知道，这真的很感人，不是吗？我们录制这期节目时，正如你所知，媒体上有很多关于以色列袭击和那里发生的暴行的报道。我参加了一个临床心理学家的私人执业讨论，她住在以色列工作，但在英国受过培训，她真的在努力帮助处于危机中的人们，但她不一定是创伤治疗师，她问：“我该怎么做？我怎么能提供帮助？”你知道，我也从事创伤工作，我说，当有这么多悬而未决的问题，当我们无法获得那种安全感时，试图帮助人们找到安全感是非常困难的。当然，当我们进行创伤工作时，部分内容是我们不得不告诉人们：“现在结束了。”你知道，当你处于持续的局势中时，你该如何做到这一点？你该如何管理它？
Yeah, million-dollar question, really. I think one of the things I've talked about in a few of the conferences we've been to or with colleagues is actually there's a collective trauma going on, you know, the psychologist that we're working with. So the role was more around know the the psychologist that we're working with so it's more the role was more around training up the psychologist getting a sense of what they're working with and perhaps identifying needs um but they're going through trauma they're you know they're listening to the radio watching the news every day there's a lot of people that they know have been
是的，这真是个价值百万美元的问题。我认为我在我们参加的一些会议上或与同事讨论过的一件事是，实际上正在发生一种集体创伤。你知道，我们合作的心理学家，所以这个角色更多是关于培训心理学家，了解他们正在处理的情况，也许识别需求，但他们正在经历创伤。他们每天都在听广播、看新闻，他们认识的很多人都受伤了、
hurt killed or friends of friends etc so it's all very close to home. So them trying to manage their own well-being, for want of a better word, is really tricky. I think because there was, I suppose, a spinal cord injury or SCI center and a traumatic brain injury center as well, there was certainly a degree of trying to get the patients or the clients through rehabilitation or get them engaged in rehabilitation to minimise their difficulties further down the line. But there's lots of other things coming up,
被杀害了，或者朋友的朋友等等，所以这一切都离他们很近。所以他们试图管理自己的福祉，用一个更好的词来说，真的很棘手。我认为因为那里有一个脊髓损伤中心和一个创伤性脑损伤中心，肯定在某种程度上试图让患者或客户完成康复，或者让他们参与康复，以尽量减少他们以后的困难。但还有很多其他事情出现，
lots of guys with PTSD, lots of anxiety, lots of low mood, lots of maladaptive coping strategies. So almost trying to unpick that as well and trying to navigate it and then also displacement so millions of people have had to move and millions of people can't go back to where they are from so even just trying to get these guys back or discharged from the hospital is a real a real tricky thing um i've been really impressed though with you know for saying in ukraine there's not a formal pathway for psychologists a lot of the stuff they're doing is similar to what we do but perhaps not necessarily with our uh clinical training or uh evidence base or sort of theory practice links but it it does make sense um so i think for me is trying to provide them or help
很多患有创伤后应激障碍（PTSD）的人，很多焦虑，很多情绪低落，很多适应不良的应对策略。所以几乎也要试图解开这些，并试图驾驭它，还有流离失所的问题，数百万人不得不搬迁，数百万人无法回到他们原来的地方，所以即使只是试图让这些人出院也是一件非常棘手的事情。不过，我对乌克兰的情况印象深刻，那里没有正式的心理学家途径，他们做的很多事情和我们做的类似，但可能不一定具备我们的临床培训、证据基础或理论实践联系，但它确实有意义。所以我想对我来说，是试图为他们提供或帮助
them think about core skills um so there's things like um motivational interviewing techniques and even just goal setting um also thinking about uh adjustment after spinal injury. But with me only being out there effectively two or three months, I was never going to be able to train them in a therapeutic orientation. So we were trying to recommend that the WHO and the Ukrainian Ministry of Health look at getting them formal or accredited qualifications in things like CBT and in EMDR because it's a recognition to the fact that those things would be helpful for a variety of reasons for the patients they were working with. So, yeah, really multifactorial. And like I say, it's difficult to concentrate on one thing when there's a backdrop of systemic problems that you're not going to be able to resolve.
他们思考核心技能。所以有一些东西，比如动机访谈技术，甚至只是目标设定，还有思考脊髓损伤后的调整。但由于我实际上只在那里待了两三个月，我永远无法在治疗方向上培训他们。所以我们试图建议世界卫生组织和乌克兰卫生部考虑让他们获得CBT和EMDR等方面的正式或认证资格，因为这承认了这些东西对他们正在治疗的患者有多种原因的帮助。所以，确实是多因素的。就像我说的，当背景中存在你无法解决的系统性问题时，很难专注于一件事。
Absolutely. And I guess it's knowing that what you're not going to be able to resolve. Absolutely. And I guess it's knowing that what you're doing is all that can be done right now and that it's helpful and worthwhile. Yeah, that's something I've reflected on a fair bit because, again, I knew I was doing a relatively short-term contract and I knew I wouldn't be able to do everything that would be possible, the sort of moral injury side of things. But I suppose being in amongst that system, that ecosystem,
绝对是。我想知道你所做的一切就是现在能做的全部，而且它是有帮助和值得的。是的，这是我反思过很多次的事情，因为同样，我知道我签的是一份相对短期的合同，我知道我无法完成所有可能的事情，比如道德伤害那一方面。但我想，身处那个系统、那个生态系统中，
you get more of an idea of what the government are doing or how the people are seeing things. So Zelensky's wife is the first lady, and she's very much on the mental health ticket. She's really promoting that stuff for civilians, the military but also those providing care um and i think from talking to the psychologists in ukraine as well um mental health is taboo um it is it is in most places they feel it's very much so out there very proud country but i think this is bringing it to the surface and i think it might be changing the culture in some ways and in trying to um say
你会更了解政府在做什么，或者人们是如何看待事物的。泽连斯基的妻子是第一夫人，她非常关注心理健康。她真的在为平民、军人以及那些提供护理的人推广这些东西。而且我认为从与乌克兰的心理学家交谈来看，心理健康是一个禁忌，在大多数地方都是如此。他们觉得在那里确实如此，这是一个非常自豪的国家，但我认为这正在将其浮出水面，我认为这可能会在某些方面改变文化，并试图
that it doesn't can happen to people and we need to think about how we support people before during and after in order to to try and help people get better absolutely and you know to be human is to you know actually absolutely be unifying but it sounds like actually it's just it's culture and kind of traditions that dictate how mental health is responded to but actually the symptoms of mental health are pretty pretty consistent across our human population yeah yeah i think um yeah i think you're right there i think there's definitely cultural language difficulties or differences but there's often commonalities that we can see between people as well i'm intrigued in your opinion so today um i've been on lbc radio because um a very big newspaper in the UK had decided to print a really emotive photo.
说这确实会发生在人们身上，我们需要考虑如何在之前、期间和之后支持人们，以试图帮助人们好转。绝对是，你知道，作为人类，这确实是统一的，但听起来这只是文化和传统决定了如何应对心理健康，但实际上心理健康的症状在整个人类群体中是相当一致的。是的，是的，我想你是对的。我认为肯定存在文化语言上的困难或差异，但我们也能看到人与人之间的共同点。我对你的观点很感兴趣，所以今天，我上了LBC电台，因为英国一家非常大的报纸决定刊登一张非常感人的照片。
I won't share too much information about it in case it's triggering for people. But the question I was asked is, was it right to print that? Is there a responsibility to print that? And they were really pushing me on that and I was sort of dancing around that topic because you know in essence my answer is maybe not in baby loss awareness week you know there's better times we could do that um but it's so triggering to people this kind of emotive photography what's your viewpoint on that Alistair? So obviously I'm not not an expert in it but I did go to a talk at the European Congress of Psychology in Brighton over the summer and they had a an expert from the US on this very topic
我不会分享太多关于它的信息，以防对人们造成触发。但我被问到的问题是，刊登它对吗？有责任刊登它吗？他们真的在逼问我，我当时在那个话题上绕圈子，因为本质上我的回答是，也许在婴儿丧失意识周（Baby Loss Awareness Week）不应该这样做，你知道，有更好的时间我们可以这样做，但这对人们来说太容易触发了，这种感人的摄影。Alistair，你对此有什么看法？显然我不是这方面的专家，但我夏天在布莱顿举行的欧洲心理学大会上听过一次讲座，他们请了一位来自美国的专家专门谈论这个话题，
and her advice was if there's news stories with images that are potentially traumatizing then she covers them up she doesn't click on the videos she might read the text but she's their evidence is that if you engage with the picture or the video you're more likely to get secondary traumatization than you were if you just to read the text so that's not my opinion but i well i i get it i agree with it and i'm trying to practice that a bit to myself um but that's where they sat with it um yeah i wouldn't all like to comment on the the moral duty of a newspaper because it's difficult because you've got raising awareness of things that are going on versus how do you do that and what content do you put out there for others to see yeah i agree and in the pre-production
她的建议是，如果有带有潜在创伤性图像的新闻报道，她会把它们遮住，她不会点击视频，她可能会阅读文字，但他们的证据是，如果你接触了图片或视频，你比只阅读文字更容易受到二次创伤。所以那不是我的观点，但我明白，我同意它，我正在尝试对自己实践这一点。但这就是他们的立场。是的，我不想评论报纸的道德义务，因为这很困难，因为你既要提高对正在发生的事情的认识，又要考虑如何做到这一点，以及你向他人展示什么内容。是的，我同意。在预制作
chat that i'd had um i was saying you know this this does kind of make us aware of what humanity is capable of you know in terms of the compassionate focus trauma you know approach you know humans are capable of doing really awful things on purpose to other people um but also we're capable of imagining you know we don't necessarily need to see a photo to you know to have it paint a thousand words um and sometimes you don't need to see pictures of people that are wounded sometimes just the setting where they've been wounded is equally as powerful you know I'm still struck with the the images of when Osama bin Laden was was captured killed that was really really powerful you didn't see him but you saw the room and that's you know it is powerful and I guess when we're working with
聊天中，我说过，这确实让我们意识到人类的能力，你知道，在同情聚焦创伤方法方面，你知道，人类有能力故意对他人做非常可怕的事情。但我们也能够想象，你知道，我们不一定需要看到照片来让它描绘出一千个字。有时你不需要看到受伤的人的照片，有时仅仅是他们受伤的环境也同样强大。你知道，我仍然对奥萨马·本·拉登被抓获、击毙时的图像印象深刻，那真的非常强大。你没有看到他，但你看到了那个房间，那是，你知道，它很强大。我想当我们与
people who either are traumatized or have been traumatized there's a real impact of vicarious trauma both upon ourselves but you know upon people that you'll have been working with as well um how do we look after ourselves in terms of the carers trauma how have you been looking after yourself yeah i think before i went out i was trying to make sure trying to think about that before i needed to um and you know it's interesting, the first, when I went out in December, we were in a hotel that was slightly out of the city that we were based in. And, you know, we'd go to work in the morning,
那些受到创伤或曾经受到创伤的人一起工作时，替代性创伤对我们自己以及你曾经一起工作过的人都有真正的影响。我们在照顾者创伤方面如何照顾自己？你是如何照顾自己的？是的，我想在我出发之前，我就在尝试思考这一点，在需要之前。而且，你知道，很有趣，第一次，当我在12月出发时，我们住的酒店离我们驻扎的城市稍微远一点。而且，你知道，我们早上会去工作，
get back at four-ish, but it was winter, it was cold, it was dark, there's nothing else around particularly. You think about the things that we do around achievement connection i suppose enjoy enjoyment you know um internet connectivity was poor so it's difficult to speak to people back home or even just go on social media to connect with people or stream stuff um there wasn't a gym in the hotel so you couldn't necessarily do anything to keep yourself active um you couldn't go out for a walk because we're on a dual carriageway the nearest thing was like a supermarket half a
四点左右回来，但那是冬天，很冷，很黑，周围没什么特别的。你思考我们在成就、联系方面所做的事情，我想还有享受，你知道，互联网连接很差，所以很难与家里的人交谈，甚至很难上网与人联系或流媒体播放东西。酒店里没有健身房，所以你不能一定要做点什么来保持活跃。你不能出去散步，因为我们在双车道公路上，最近的东西是半英里外的一家超市。
mile away and so i i felt that the first time around i thought you know i took out some gym gear to work out in the room um i tried to think about eating healthily but that's very difficult when you're living in a hotel um so i think as a i suppose as a who team we sort of agreed that we'd move into the city for the for the january to march phase because for me i wanted to be a part of and i like to go for a coffee or i like to go to the gym or i like to have a few options once i get back from work and that was a really strong move to i suppose be closer to it and also we're able to experience the ukrainian culture a bit more you know i i went to a coffee shop regularly in the morning and they got to know my order um i went i joined a gym and
所以我第一次去的时候感觉，我想，你知道，我带了一些健身装备在房间里锻炼。我尝试考虑健康饮食，但当你住在酒店时这非常困难。所以我认为作为一个世卫组织团队，我们同意在1月到3月阶段搬进城市，因为对我来说，我想成为其中的一部分，我喜欢去喝杯咖啡，或者我喜欢去健身房，或者我喜欢在下班后有几个选择。这是一个非常强有力的举措，我想，更接近它，而且我们能够更多地体验乌克兰文化。你知道，我每天早上都会去一家咖啡店，他们熟悉我的订单。我加入了一家健身房，
went to that like several times a week and that was great for me because you know i usually go out mountain biking or swimming or going to the gym and stuff um there were lots of restaurants we could go to so again sort of like dipping into that I think in addition to that you've also got to think about what you eat so my routine when I've had to think about why I eat when I get back because you know I probably put about 10 pounds from just sort of living the life and eating in hotels or restaurants three times a day and then I suppose the other things is trying to think about, again, foundation stuff, but, you know, not drinking particularly.
每周去几次，这对我很棒，因为你知道，我通常会去山地自行车、游泳或去健身房之类的。有很多餐馆我们可以去，所以同样是那种体验。我认为除此之外，你还必须考虑你吃什么。所以我的日常安排是我必须考虑我回来时吃什么，因为你知道，我可能因为过着那种生活，每天在酒店或餐馆吃三顿饭而胖了大约10磅。然后我想其他事情是试图思考，同样，基础的东西，但是，你知道，不要特别喝酒。
You know, I'm not a big drinker, but I'd have to make sure that I watched that because it's quite easy to, when you're meeting new people or you've got sort of meetings with officials, you have a drink or the tradition around it. And sleep, sleeping somewhere different i'm not gonna lie there were air raids or air raid sirens you know sort of every couple of days and they could be any time of the day they could be in the middle of the night they could be for 10 minutes it could be for three hours so it's trying to think about you know i often sleep with earplugs
你知道，我不是一个大酒鬼，但我必须确保我注意这一点，因为当你遇到新朋友或者你与官员有某种会议时，喝一杯或周围的传统很容易。还有睡眠，睡在不同的地方，我不会撒谎，有空袭或空袭警报，你知道，每隔几天就有一次，它们可能在一天中的任何时间，可能在半夜，可能持续10分钟，可能持续三个小时。所以这是试图思考，你知道，我经常戴着耳塞睡觉，
and eye masks they definitely came with me had some herbal sleeping stuff that I took occasionally but that was just to try and keep me going because um it's easy to say but you're in threat mode most of the time and the work we were doing was pretty intense I was also trying to navigate doing stuff back here um by either providing supervision or dipping in on more complex cases that I'd left behind so it's almost like give yourself permission say actually I'll dip out of this or I'd not go to that or I need to I'm going to give myself permission to self-care a bit um it's all very well and good saying that but it's very hard to do it so I think for me going out there and having that was really important and then when I came back you know it probably take anything from a few days to maybe a week or so to just uh decompress you know I wasn't like up here but I was a bit more down you know
还有眼罩，它们绝对和我一起来了。有一些草药睡眠产品，我偶尔会吃，但这只是为了试图让我坚持下去，因为，你知道，这很容易说，但你大部分时间都处于威胁模式，我们所做的工作非常紧张。我也在试图处理在这里做的事情，通过提供监督或深入参与我留下的更复杂的案例。所以这几乎就像给自己许可说，实际上我会退出这个，或者我不去那个，或者我需要，我要给自己许可进行一点自我护理。这说起来容易做起来难，所以我认为对我来说，去那里并拥有那个是非常重要的。然后当我回来时，你知道，可能需要几天到一周左右的时间来解压，你知道，我没有像这里这样，但我有点低落，你知道，
sort of the sort of the uh counter counter side to that so again for me is trying to do stuff with my wife and my dog and meet mates or organize a night or a day where i'd go actually i'll put this in the diary because when i come back i might not want to do that but if there's something already organized it's kind of in the offing um so yeah just i suppose being for me being a bit organized thinking ahead of time about stuff that i know is good for me and then trying to stick to it or getting other people to remind me for it you know i think um after say that one of my trainees that was back in salford you know before i went out i was like checking on me because i might be a bit more irritable than normal i might be a bit tired and she was great at just
那种反面。所以对我来说，再次尝试和我的妻子、我的狗做点事情，见见朋友，或者组织一个晚上或一天，我会去，实际上我会把它写在日记里，因为当我回来时，我可能不想那样做，但如果已经组织好了什么，它就在计划中。所以，是的，只是，我想对我来说，组织一点，提前考虑我知道对我好的事情，然后尝试坚持下去，或者让别人提醒我。你知道，我想，在索尔福德的一位学员，在我出发前，她会检查我，因为我可能比平时更易怒，我可能有点累，她非常擅长只是
sort of asking that question um because again when you're in a perceived perceived position of power people don't necessarily ask um but it was really good just to have someone that within a safe space almost like a peer supervision element just to try and make sure that you know i'm not going down a path or that i'm not thinking too much i'd say yeah so yeah there was a few things that you know we teach others to do and i wanted to practice what we preach um i haven't done anything specific in terms of supervision or seeking i suppose uh counseling support because i don't think it's i've been one step separate from that and it was short-term basis but you know if that comes up in the future that's not something i would shy away from for
问那个问题，因为同样，当你处于感知的权力位置时，人们不一定会问。但有一个人在一个安全的空间里，几乎像一个同伴监督元素，这真的很好，只是为了确保，你知道，我没有走上一条路，或者我没有想太多。我会说，是的，所以，是的，有一些我们教别人做的事情，我想身体力行。我没有在监督或寻求心理咨询支持方面做任何具体的事情，因为我不认为这是，我离那一步还有一步之遥，而且是短期的。但你知道，如果未来出现这种情况，那不是我会回避的事情。
sure oh i mean you said the words right out of my mouth but you really have been practicing what we preach you know the the basics of eating sleeping activity scheduling you know trying to look for the things that you know keep you well generally and trying to see what you can do to to keep those as constant as possible but um it made me made me think about some of my conversations with my um with the people that were staying with my mum and they were like there's too many too many vegetables here in this country we need more meat we need yeah yeah and so I can see how if that's kind of what you were around that you might have put on more weight than you're used to as well very much so it's a lot harder to lose when you're a bit older as well oh yeah i hear you i hear you um but you
当然。哦，我的意思是，你说了我想说的话，但你真的在身体力行，你知道，饮食、睡眠、活动安排的基础知识，你知道，试图寻找那些你知道能让你保持健康的事情，并试图看看你能做些什么来让这些尽可能保持不变。但是，这让我想起了一些我和我妈妈接待的人的谈话，他们说，这个国家的蔬菜太多了，我们需要更多的肉，我们需要……是的，是的。所以我可以看到，如果那是你周围的情况，你可能比你习惯的胖得更多。非常多，当你年纪大一点时，减肥也难得多。哦，是的，我听到了，我听到了。但是，你
know i was i've been it's only the second time i've met you um i follow you on twitter and was trying to follow your exploits on there a little bit we're allowed to say twitter anymore i don't think we are x whatever it is um but you know like your parents i was worried about you yeah sadly when you were there there there were two British journalists, it turned out, who were missing and did not survive. But to begin with, that was reported as two British men. Everybody who knows you and everybody who knows them, of course, would have been thinking, oh, gosh, oh, gosh.
知道，我，这是我第二次见到你，我在推特上关注你，并试图在上面关注你的事迹。我们还能说推特吗？我不认为我们还能说，X，不管它是什么。但是，你知道，像你的父母一样，我很担心你。是的，可悲的是，当你还在那里时，有两名英国记者，事实证明，他们失踪了，没有幸存。但起初，这被报道为两名英国男子。每个认识你的人，当然，每个认识他们的人，都会想，哦，天哪，哦，天哪。
And it's very difficult. It wasn't easy for you either. thinking, oh, gosh, oh, gosh, you know, and it's very difficult. Yeah. It wasn't easy for you either. It's tricky because I also wasn't allowed to say where I was. And there were people who did know, but I think from my side, I was able to tell broadly people back home where I was, and I was sort of northwestern Ukraine, which is very reassuring when you think how far away it is from things but the airline say people who slightly more removed or might be able to who who won't
这非常困难。这对你来说也不容易。想，哦，天哪，哦，天哪，你知道，这非常困难。是的。这对你来说也不容易。这很棘手，因为我也不被允许说我在哪里。有些人确实知道，但我认为从我这边来看，我能够大致告诉家里的人我在哪里，我在乌克兰西北部，当你想到它离事情有多远时，这非常令人放心。但航空公司说，那些稍微远离的人，或者可能能够，那些不会
got a message from me just in general um were wondering what was going on and interestingly a lot of my friends who i worked with out there from the who's have still been working out there and it's been harder for me back here seeing what's going on out there and then going oh gosh is that is that near you or there is something near them and worrying about them more now i'm back than i was about myself when i was out there i felt far safer when i was out there than people might my thoughts i would have been so yeah that was that was odd um but yeah i think um i mean it's always it was funny telling my my mum and my dad about it because my mum worked for the nhs for 40 or 50 years as a nurse and she did a bit of work in
收到我的消息，一般情况下，都在想发生了什么。有趣的是，我在那里一起工作的很多世卫组织的朋友仍然在那里工作，我回来后看到那里发生的事情，然后说，哦，天哪，那离你近吗？或者那里附近有东西，现在我回来后比我在那里时更担心他们。我在那里时感觉比人们可能想的要安全得多。所以，是的，那很奇怪。但是，是的，我想，我的意思是，告诉我的妈妈和爸爸这件事总是很有趣，因为我妈妈作为护士为NHS工作了40或50年，她在那个时期在香港做了一些工作，
in hong kong over that time and so she was used she she was sort of used to the idea of doing a bit of work away um but i think i i told her you know all oh you know i've got a job it's really exciting um i'm going to be working for the who she said oh that's amazing that's fantastic and then she goes where i was like oh in ukraine and then that i took a screenshot of it at the time because i was but she it was crestfallen but at the same time there's so much pride in it and i think um i think that was the heartening thing i didn't want to make people too worried or too upset but at the same time it's a very uh just thing to be doing um and i think if i thought it was too dangerous i would have just probably pulled out or um tried to end
所以她习惯了，她习惯了在外面工作一段时间的想法。但我认为我告诉她，你知道，哦，你知道，我有一份工作，这真的很令人兴奋，我要为世卫组织工作。她说，哦，那太棒了，那太美妙了。然后她说，在哪里？我说，哦，在乌克兰。然后我当时截了屏，因为我当时……但她，她当时很沮丧，但同时又感到非常自豪。我认为，我认为那是令人振奋的事情。我不想让人们太担心或太难过，但同时，这是一件非常正义的事情。而且我认为如果我觉得它太危险，我可能就会退出，或者试图提前结束
the contract early so yeah it's difficult isn't it we have it in the uk if there's a major incident in london i've had that with friends 2007 mates working in london and the bus bombing and i was like oh gosh and there's the whole check-in thing and that sort of stuff so yeah i've seen it from the other side um i think i think that's the thing isn't it i was struck by that today so just before we met i popped to aldi um to get some bits and pieces and i bought myself a new pair of slippers which I'm very excited about. This is the thing isn't it people are just going about their normal lives and you know even in Israel this time last week people were just out there buying slippers and
合同。所以，是的，这很困难，不是吗？我们在英国也有这种情况，如果伦敦发生重大事件，我2007年有朋友在伦敦工作，当时发生了公交车爆炸案，我就想，哦，天哪，还有整个签到之类的事情。所以，是的，我从另一面看到了它。我想，我想这就是重点，不是吗？我今天对此印象深刻。所以就在我们见面之前，我去了阿尔迪（Aldi）买了一些零碎的东西，我给自己买了一双新拖鞋，我非常兴奋。这就是重点，不是吗？人们只是在过着他们正常的生活，你知道，即使在以色列，上周这个时候，人们也只是在那里买拖鞋和
dishwasher tablets you know and it's when it just catches you in the middle of your ordinary life it's really derailing yeah i think um i'm supposed to reflect on what it looked like out there as well there is a new normal for the guys in ukraine um there's a curfew still at 11 p.m for everyone across the country um there's air raids and people are supposed to go to air raid shelters but depending on where you are you're more or less likely to do that because there's an app that tells you there's an air raid. There's also people messaging saying, oh, no, it's not here. It's gone past here, et cetera. Everyone's got power banks because phones and electricity can go down.
洗碗机药片。你知道，当它在你的普通生活中突然抓住你时，它真的很让人崩溃。是的，我想，我应该反思一下那里看起来是什么样子。乌克兰的人们有一种新常态，全国每个人仍然有晚上11点的宵禁。有空袭，人们应该去防空洞，但取决于你在哪里，你更有可能或不太可能这样做，因为有一个应用程序会告诉你发生了空袭。还有人发消息说，哦，不，这里没有。它已经过去了，等等。每个人都有充电宝，因为手机和电力可能会中断。
Similarly, you walk down the high street, every shop's got sort of a petrol generator outside when the power cuts happen. The transport infrastructure has been affected because they've had to invest in the military. So getting around is a lot harder. The roads are a lot more cut up. But, you know, there's a big belief amongst the Ukrainian population about winning
同样，你走在商业街上，当停电发生时，每家店外面都有某种汽油发电机。交通基础设施受到了影响，因为他们不得不投资于军事。所以出行要困难得多。道路被切断得更多。但是，你知道，乌克兰民众中有一种关于胜利的巨大信念，
and also that this is the right thing to do. And I think that's reflected in some of the people who've joined the effort from neighbouring countries because they're worried about being next so it's a really really interesting one because they have I suppose have adjusted to it but it's still not right. One of the things that was really telling was one of our drivers was talking about you know if an air raid happens during school hours the school shuts so parents have to go get the kids pull them out of school i'm like well i said there's a generational trauma about to happen or what the generational effects of people not getting adequate access to education over time what does
而且这也是正确的事情。我认为这反映在一些从邻国加入努力的人身上，因为他们担心成为下一个。所以这是一个非常非常有趣的问题，因为他们已经，我想，适应了它，但这仍然是不对的。其中一件非常能说明问题的事情是，我们的一位司机在谈论，你知道，如果空袭发生在学校时间，学校就会关闭，所以父母必须去接孩子，把他们从学校拉出来。我说，好吧，我说，一场代际创伤即将发生，或者人们随着时间的推移无法获得足够的教育机会的代际影响是什么？
affect people going into employment you know lots of working age men are in the military um so yeah there's there's just a lot of dynamics where people have sort of accepted a new norm but there's no end point in science how do you carry on that on really yeah really important questions really important questions and i guess we're we're humans and we adapt, don't we? Because what are the other choices, you know? No, it's just such a huge question, isn't it? You know, we've not experienced wartime in our country.
影响人们就业，你知道很多适龄男性都在军队，所以有很多动态因素，人们似乎接受了一种新常态，但在科学中没有终点，你如何真正继续下去？确实是非常重要的问题，我想我们是人类，我们适应了，不是吗？因为还有什么其他选择呢？不，这真是一个巨大的问题，不是吗？你知道，我们国家还没有经历过战时状态。
You know, there's a few generations back you have, but it's very different when you see it first hand or even second hand you know and i just had not imagined there'd be an air raid app you know there are apps for everything but they are pretty useful it's a pretty useful app to have if you need it it's incredible yeah again i didn't think that would be the case but i think you know i've had friends who've been out in japan and they get warnings about tornadoes and i was oh yeah that makes sense and then it was when i got to ukraine oh yeah you need to download this this will tell you when the air raid starts and when it stops and you know um where we were staying as well they had a siren and it is what you hear in the films from the blitz it's exactly that and it's like you feel like you're transported
你知道，往回推几代人经历过，但亲眼所见或甚至间接了解是非常不同的。我真没想到会有空袭警报应用程序，你知道什么都有应用程序，但它们确实很有用，如果你需要的话，这是一个非常有用的应用程序。这太不可思议了，是的，我再次没想到会这样，但我认为你知道，我有朋友在日本，他们会收到龙卷风警报，我当时想，哦，是的，这很有道理。然后当我到了乌克兰，哦，是的，你需要下载这个，它会告诉你空袭什么时候开始，什么时候结束。而且你知道，我们住的地方也有警报器，和你从电影里听到的闪电战警报声一模一样，感觉就像被传送了一样。
back in time and it's a very evocative um noise um very very loud obviously but it's just again it's something that'll stick with me you know when i hear something on the tv i was like oh sort of transported back not in a reliving sense but it's just reminiscent you know so it's loud but you know i don't know if you've ever been to a sound bath class but some certain frequencies resonate in your body you know do you have that do you have that experience with it i suppose thinking about it now not i had i usually had earplugs in um but yeah i don't think i had that per se but i think i'd probably acclimatized to it in a way i don't know if you know i've been we've holidayed like heptabridging they've had similar sirens around flooding um so i wonder you know i wonder
回到过去，这是一种非常令人回味的噪音，显然非常非常响，但这再次让我印象深刻。你知道，当我在电视上听到类似的声音时，我会想，哦，好像被传送回去了，不是那种重温的感觉，只是让人想起。所以它很响，但我不知道你是否去过声音浴课程，但某些频率会在你的身体里产生共鸣，你知道吗？你有过那种经历吗？我想现在回想起来，我通常戴着耳塞，但我认为我并没有那种特定的感觉，但我认为我已经以某种方式适应了它。我不知道你是否知道，我们去过像赫普布里奇那样的地方度假，他们周围有类似的洪水警报器，所以我很好奇，我很好奇
if there's a certain pitch they have it so it is like say resonating in a in a very physical way yeah oh i've got so many questions and conversations to have with you. But, you know, if people are moved or intrigued about what we're talking about, is there a best place they can learn or is there a best place they can offer any support themselves, Alistair? Oh, gosh, I don't know, really. I think it's tricky. I think there was a big, I suppose, a big move early on in the war about people offering support and sending things out there but i don't know how that looks at the moment um i suppose most big cities have got ukrainian communities that could reach out to um but aside from that i suppose for me i'm trying to share the good work that's being done out there and share it as a mental health is on the agenda
如果它们有某种特定的音调，让它以一种非常物理的方式产生共鸣。是的，我有太多的问题和对话想和你交流。但是，如果人们被我们谈论的内容所触动或感兴趣，有没有最好的地方可以让他们了解，或者有没有最好的地方可以让他们自己提供支持，阿利斯泰尔？哦，天哪，我真的不知道。我认为这很棘手。我想在战争初期，人们提供支持并运送物资过去，这曾是一个很大的举动，但我不知道目前情况如何。我想大多数大城市都有可以联系的乌克兰社区，但除此之外，我想对我来说，我正在努力分享在那里所做的出色工作，并分享心理健康已提上议程
and the who and the ministry of health out there are pushing this but it's difficult to I suppose it's difficult to get that momentum or sometimes to know what to do and I've got I've had a very small part to play but I suppose I'm just trying to at the moment support the guys I know in being able to support more people so almost like multiplier effect you know so yeah I'm not sure really mary i'm sorry yeah okay that's all right um and you know you feel like it's a small part but i guess for me i know that the goodness that you're putting in there and the good practice and the really sound principles of how to set up a service in a compassionate, holistic way are going to be far-reaching, not just now,
世界卫生组织和那里的卫生部都在推动这一点，但很难，我想很难保持这种势头，或者有时不知道该做什么。我只发挥了很小的作用，但我认为我目前只是在努力支持我认识的人，让他们能够支持更多的人，就像乘数效应一样。所以是的，我真的不确定，玛丽，我很抱歉。是的，没关系。而且你知道，你觉得这只是很小的一部分，但我猜对我来说，我知道你投入的善意、良好的实践以及以富有同情心和整体的方式建立服务的真正健全的原则，将产生深远的影响，不仅是现在，
but in years and years to come. So I think, you know, I feel really proud of you as a human, but also really proud of the profession that you've been able to do that and you've been able to offer that at such an important time for that country. So, you know, not my place to be proud of you but I am all the same and thank you for doing this really important work and to share your skills so richly and freely you know at risk to yourself no um you know thank you it's
而且在未来的岁月里。所以我认为，你知道，我为你作为一个人类感到非常自豪，也为你能够做到这一点并能够在那个国家如此重要的时刻提供这种帮助而为这个职业感到自豪。所以，你知道，虽然我不该为你感到骄傲，但我依然为你感到骄傲，感谢你做这项非常重要的工作，并如此慷慨地分享你的技能，甚至冒着生命危险。不，你知道，谢谢你，这
very very nice of you to say I think it's always nice to hear isn't it that people are proud of you and glad that you've done what you've done. I don't think I'd say that's why I did it. Four is something I thought I can do. It's within my zone of proximal development. It's within my wheelhouse to a degree, but perhaps a bit of a stretch. But, yeah, I think when I was leaving Ukraine and when I was finishing out there,
非常非常感谢你这么说。我认为听到人们为你感到骄傲并为你所做的事情感到高兴总是件好事。我不认为我会说这就是我做这件事的原因。这是我认为我能做的事情。它在我的最近发展区内。在某种程度上，它在我的能力范围内，尽管可能有点挑战。但是，是的，我想当我离开乌克兰时，当我结束在那里的工作时，
you got a sense of the outpouring of the gratitude. And, you know, when you're walking down the streets, people are generally like, why are you here? And then when they find out, there's similar sort of a bit of amazement, but also then a real outpouring of love and affection for the fact that you're actually wanting to put yourself in that situation. And I was probably a bit blasé about it at the start I'm probably still a bit now but yeah I think over time I'll probably think about the gravity of it and I think seeing the
你感受到了那种倾泻而出的感激之情。而且，你知道，当你走在街上时，人们通常会问，你为什么在这里？然后当他们发现原因时，会有类似的惊讶，但随后也会因为你实际上愿意让自己处于那种境地而产生真正的爱和感情。我刚开始时可能有点漫不经心，现在可能仍然有点，但我想随着时间的推移，我可能会思考它的重要性。我想看到
psychologist particularly sort of like Nadia who's one of the ones I've been mentoring and seeing how she's come on since I first went out there and she was almost learning and sitting in the stuff I was doing to now when she's delivering teaching or CPD for others is great. And like I said, hopefully there's just a thin foundation that they can then build on and provide to others, because previously it's probably been it's not been a particularly popular profession, similar to OT, relatively new or sort of undersourced or lack of structure. So hopefully, unfortunately, this has brought it to the surface, but hopefully there is some good coming out of it in terms of
心理学家，特别是像纳迪亚这样的人，她是我一直在指导的人之一，看到她从我第一次去那里以来的进步，她几乎是在学习和旁听我所做的事情，到现在她正在为其他人提供教学或持续专业发展（CPD），这太棒了。就像我说的，希望这只是一个他们可以以此为基础并提供给其他人的薄弱基础，因为以前这可能不是一个特别受欢迎的职业，类似于职业治疗（OT），相对较新，或者资源不足，缺乏结构。所以希望，不幸的是，这已经把它带到了表面，但希望它在以下方面带来了一些好处
the public perception of psychology being changed. Anna, you're making me think about when I've worked with service personnel and when I've worked with people that work in the police and in the fire service you know it's often a certain breed of person that is able to run towards things that people would usually run away from would you say you're kind of a white knuckle sort of adrenaline sort of guy generally or is that is this I was going to say no but then I'll probably then you probably ask me a follow-up question about oh yeah i've done that and i've done that and i've done that so i think i do i do those sort of things but i'm not sort of i'm not necessarily an adrenaline junkie but i do um
公众对心理学的看法正在改变。安娜，你让我想起我与服务人员以及在警察和消防部门工作的人一起工作的时候，你知道，通常是某种特定类型的人能够冲向人们通常会逃离的地方。你会说你通常是一个喜欢肾上腺素的人吗，还是说这是……我本来想说不，但然后你可能会问我一个后续问题，关于哦是的，我做过那个，我做过那个，我做过那个。所以我认为我确实做过那些事情，但我并不一定是一个肾上腺素瘾君子，但我确实
i've always been competitive sports or done things that i think to relax i've always done something quite active um but yeah i think i think again just going back to what you're saying about so people running towards it, a lot of the guys we saw out there were military, obviously. And I suppose there's a lot of them who wanted to get straight back into it or felt guilty about not being able to go back. And for me, I was just like, I've never been inclined to join the military. I've always been very impassioned about people who have.
我一直喜欢竞技运动，或者做一些我认为能放松的事情，我一直做一些相当活跃的事情。但是，是的，我想我想再次回到你所说的关于人们冲向它的事情，我们在那里看到的大多数人显然是军人。我想他们中很多人想直接回到战场，或者因为不能回去而感到内疚。对我来说，我只是觉得，我从来没有倾向于参军。我一直对那些参军的人充满热情。
But it was just very humbling to see these lads with these awful injuries going okay so I want to go back and and fight for my country I want I've got a band of brothers or a band of sisters that I want to to be in amongst again so yeah I I like doing things that are energizing but yeah it's uh I wouldn't say I've run towards it quite so much no okay well thank you so much for taking time on your day off as well like it's again dedication to the cause um it's been it's been an absolute pleasure to speak with you um and thank you for coming back on again because it feels like a really important conversation and i wanted to just pay kudos to the really important work that you and your team have been doing no thank you Marion it's really nice to I suppose be invited back on and I suppose talk about
但看到这些受了可怕伤的年轻人说，好吧，我想回去为我的国家而战，我想我有一群兄弟或姐妹，我想再次和他们在一起，这真是让人谦卑。所以是的，我喜欢做一些能激发活力的事情，但是的，这……我不会说我冲向它的程度有那么高。不，好的，非常感谢你在休息日也抽出时间，这又是对事业的奉献。和你交谈绝对是一种荣幸，感谢你再次回来，因为这感觉像是一次非常重要的对话，我想向你和你的团队一直在做的非常重要的工作致敬。不，谢谢你，玛丽安，被邀请回来谈论
something different and I suppose share that psychology is not just one element and you know if there's something that takes your fancy there's an option for you to try and pursue that as you know if you if you look into it absolutely it's a multi-f to try and pursue that as you know if you look into it absolutely it's a multi-faceted career and i just you know i'm never stopped being blown away for the directions that a single psychology degree can take you and you know it's incredible stuff thank you again and uh yeah i hope you have a lovely weekend and it's restful i want you to rest i don't i want you to rest don't worry i've been out for brunch i'm gonna walk the dog everything's good okay my my desire to keep you safe is like oh let's look
不同的事情，并分享心理学不仅仅是一个要素，这真的很好。你知道，如果有什么吸引你的东西，如果你去研究它，你就有机会尝试去追求它。绝对的，这是一个多方面的职业，我只是，你知道，我从未停止过对单一心理学学位能带给你的方向感到震惊，你知道，这真是不可思议。再次感谢你，是的，希望你周末愉快，好好休息。我希望你休息，我希望你休息，别担心，我出去吃早午餐了，我要去遛狗，一切都很好。好的，我希望你安全的愿望就像，哦，让我们看看
i'm in chester i'm not anywhere ridiculous at the moment okay thank you again for your time thanks maria oh thank you so much for watching. I hope that you found that as interesting an experience to listen to or to watch if you're watching on YouTube as I did to speak to Alistair. You know, I said it all really, just what a privilege to speak to him and what incredible work he's done. And yeah, I just feel really proud of him and of our profession. I would love your thoughts on this episode. Please do come and connect with me on socials. I'm Dr. Marianne Trent everywhere. But also do come along and join the Aspiring Psychologist Community free Facebook group. Please do either watch the compassionate Q&As
我在切斯特，我现在不在任何荒谬的地方。好的，再次感谢你的时间。谢谢玛丽安。哦，非常感谢你的观看。我希望你像我与阿利斯泰尔交谈一样，觉得这是一种有趣的聆听或观看体验（如果你是在YouTube上观看的话）。你知道，我真的说完了，能与他交谈是多么荣幸，他做了多么不可思议的工作。是的，我只是为他感到非常自豪，也为我们的职业感到自豪。我很想听听你对这一集的看法。请务必在社交媒体上与我联系。我到处都是玛丽安·特伦特博士。但也请加入“有抱负的心理学家社区”免费Facebook群组。请观看富有同情心的问答
for psychology application season either live or on replay by going along to YouTube, clicking my videos, Dr. Marianne Trent, going to the live tab and you'll find them all there. They're also in the playlists. Yeah. Tell your friends if you do find this useful and if you like the sort of things and the conversations that I have and the support that I can offer, do also consider the Aspiring Psychologist membership, which is doing great things. Thank you so much for allowing me to be part of your world and for being part of mine. The next episode of the Aspiring Psychologist podcast is available from 6am on Monday. Until then, be kind to yourselves. Take care. Bye. then let this be your guide with this podcast that you'll say to be on your way to being qualified
关于心理学申请季的直播或重播，请前往YouTube，点击我的视频，玛丽安·特伦特博士，进入直播标签，你就会找到它们。它们也在播放列表中。是的。如果你觉得这很有用，如果你喜欢我所做的事情和对话，以及我能提供的支持，也请考虑“有抱负的心理学家”会员资格，它正在做伟大的事情。非常感谢你让我成为你世界的一部分，并成为我世界的一部分。下一集“有抱负的心理学家”播客将于周一早上6点发布。在那之前，善待自己。保重。再见。让这成为你的指南，通过这个播客，你会说你正在通往获得资格的道路上
it's the aspiring psychologist podcast with dr marianne my name's Jana and I'm a trainee psychological well-being practitioner I read the clinical psychologist collective book I found it really interesting about all the different stories and how people got to become a clinical psychologist. It just amazed me how many different routes there are to get there and there's no perfect way to become one. And this kind of filled me with confidence that, no, I'm not doing it wrong and put less pressure on myself. So if you're feeling a bit uneasy about becoming a clinical psychologist
这是玛丽安博士的“有抱负的心理学家”播客。我叫贾娜，我是一名心理健康从业者实习生。我读了《临床心理学家集体》这本书，我发现关于所有不同的故事以及人们如何成为临床心理学家的经历非常有趣。有多少种不同的途径可以达到目标，而且没有成为临床心理学家的完美方式，这让我感到惊讶。这让我充满了信心，不，我没有做错，也减轻了我的压力。所以如果你对成为一名临床心理学家感到有点不安
I'd definitely recommend this just to put yourself at ease and everything will be okay. But trust me you will not put the book down once you start. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我绝对推荐这本书，这会让你感到安心，一切都会好起来的。但相信我，一旦你开始读，你就不会放下这本书。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。